things like holding our breath Kate
Winslet held her breath for seven
minutes Avatar 2 the way of water is
finally here the next installment of
this epic story was an epic challenge to
make for everyone involved stick around
for all the goods number one we knew it
was coming it's called the way of water
you know you're gonna get wet you might
be hard-pressed to put it better than
these words from actor Sam Worthington
Sam wasn't sure what he was getting into
when he was asked to be a part of the
film but he knew it would be challenging
and he knew there was going to be a lot
of work in the water he wasn't wrong
Worthington explained that doing all of
that acting while holding his breath
underwater was brutal it's the hardest
thing I've ever had to do you're dealing
with the restrictions of freediving the
constraints of motion capture underwater
and you're trying to keep an emotional
Journey going while you're innately
struggling with the fear of dying number
two what took them so long it's been a
while since the release of the first
Avatar film and there was always a plan
for a sequel so what was the whole up to
put it simply Avatar 2 took forever
because James Cameron had to make sure
Avatar 4 was ready to shoot not
something you hear very often right
Avatar 2 producer John Landau said that
we did not have to hold here for
technology I think the first avatar
proved to us that we could be the
impetus to push technology to where we
needed it to go Landau clarified that
the delays happened because the
filmmaking team was determined to get
the scripts for all four planned Avatar
sequels written and finalized before
shooting for Avatar 2 even started
Landau said we felt that this project
was about getting the story right you
would never build a house until you had
the blueprint to build from the scripts
are that blueprint so we wanted to wait
till all four of those were there number
three Avatar 2 is already a record
breaker and not in the ways you might
think the way of water takes us below
the surface of Pandora for quite a long
time and this Fantastical Journey takes
on a new level of realism when you
realize the actors are usually
performing underwater and holding their
breath for some record-setting times
according to one of the film's
freediving instructors Kate Winslet has
a beastly seven minute 15 second breath
hold which is impressive this broke up
previous actors record set by Tom Cruise
during his six-minute underwater
sequence for Mission Impossible Rogue
Nation number four we want it we don't
want it we want it director James
Cameron struggled with cutting things
out of the film and with tension around
the final duration of the movie Sam
Worthington describes the film as 2
hours and 76 minutes long and however
you count it you might say that's on the
lengthy side director James Cameron
recalled I think there was a lot of
tension around the length because it's a
complicated linear narrative which is
the worst case scenario to try to cut
short one of the hardest parts of trying
to shorten a movie is keeping things
that don't Advance the plot but are
beautiful scary or suspenseful on their
own Cameron explained we could take
things out and then if I felt the Rhythm
wasn't right we could put things back in
place number five no it's not an evil
genius secret weapon underwater cameras
normally have a hard time capturing
images with the quality we would expect
from a big budget Hollywood style film
for Avatar 2 the way of water a special
camera system needed to be invented this
was because so much of the film takes
place underwater and because the actors
would actually be performing underwater
you might think it sounds like a device
from the world of Avatar but this
special camera is called the Deep X beam
splitting rig even with this special
camera system using lenses designed
specifically for filming underwater the
production had an additional problem
there were bubbles forming on the lenses
number six no bubbles please Avatar 2
actor Kate Winslet explained that the
underwater motion capture process was
extra difficult for both the motion
capture system as well as the actors
because the actors were not allowed to
breathe out Kate explains then you have
a helmet with a helmet cam that's that
can see every single movement and muscle
and twitch and flicker on your face she
had it you're holding your breath you
can't release your bubbles otherwise
it's just a bubbly old mess and the
camera doesn't see anything which would
mean having to redo the take which is a
little more complicated than usual when
you are 20 feet underwater it was yeah a
lot to learn number seven how do you not
look like a blowfish looking back Sam
Worthington expressed some of the actors
concerns when they were approaching the
challenge of filming so many underwater
scenes for Avatar 2 the way of water the
challenge was not necessarily holding
their breath underwater for so long but
getting any effective acting done while
doing so action that's you know this
Jim's wheelhouse it's how do you do
emotion underwater how do you look at
each other with such love when you're
you know 20 feet under the water number
eight these actors got all trained up
while Avatar 2 might have seen very long
delays in production sometimes an
undertaking as big as making these
movies just takes a long time part of
the long preparation was the extensive
training the actors had to go through
before they could safely or even if
effectively begin shooting The Story
actor Zoe Saldana said he had us working
with like world-renowned redivers for
weeks on end the actress added we were
holding our breaths and really getting
our bodies acclimated to the water and
to the kind of depth that we were going
to be shooting in it turned out the
training wasn't only effective and
allowed for the magic of the story to
come to life but provided some pleasant
surprises for the cast as well we
managed to break records even for
ourselves that we never thought we would
do number nine these two go way back
Avatar 2 director James Cameron has
worked with Kate Winslet before Cameron
directed Winslet in the film Titanic and
Kate has spoken publicly about her
struggles with James and the harsh
shooting conditions speaking about her
experience on the Epic movie Winslet
called Cameron a really tough nut to
crack adding there were times I was
genuinely frightened of him Kate has
also said he has a temper like you
wouldn't believe you'd have to pay me a
lot of money to work with Jim again so
it may have been a surprise to hear that
she was working with him again on Avatar
2. James suggested that Winslet was
willing to work with him again because
she had something to prove to herself
number 10. mirror mirror on the ceiling
Avatar 2 the way of water uses a motion
capture system to capture the physical
performances of the actors and bring
their animated characters to life this
motion capture system relies on many
cameras being able to see the actors and
track the movements of small markers
worn on the actor's bodies and faces one
of the challenges of working underwater
with this is that the surface of the
water when viewed from both above and
below forms a moving mirror director
James Cameron explains that moving
mirror reflects all the dots and markers
and it creates a bunch of false markers
it's a little bit like a fighter plane
dumping a bunch of chaff to confuse the
radar system of a missile to address
this problem the team discovered that
they could pour thousands of plastic
balls into the pool to cover the surface
of the water without preventing the
actors or the crew from being able to
surface when and if they needed to can
you imagine shooting a movie underwater
interacting with CGI and then just doing
it all over again right after we'd hope
you'd understand because you were in
avatar The Way of water if not just let
the Gaston crew explain a little of the
magic behind the madness that was this
epic adventure this is not a squad it is
a family Avatar 2 did need to work hand
in hand with CGI for the film to work
but it relied a lot more on the acting
specifically with facial expressions
each actor was rigged up with a camera
that pointed at their face close up just
to make sure not even an eyebrow twitch
was left out in post those dots around
their mouths and eyes are just little
bits of marker to allow the CGI to pick
up on the even finer and more subtle
Expressions the actor creates the
emotion the actor creates the moment
James Cameron thought of everything when
building the sets he didn't just leave
it up to the digital artists he and his
team created Platforms in sound stages
to emulate the scenes they were moving
it and because working on CGI when
combined with real actors can be rather
difficult to get accurately he built
small pieces of the digital scene that
the actors would bump into but more on
that one a little later Keith said she
had a tough time getting used to
interacting with digital Monsters she
reminisces on a little mishap on set
when she accidentally stabbed
incorrectly at a fake monster that's
quite tricky because you think you're
gonna Ram it into somebody he wasn't
even there it took her a few times to
finally get it right and this
embarrassing moment just broke her into
the world of Pandora we can't judge Sam
as the language of the navi is quite
difficult to get a grasp on I'd have to
win them rope you have to write them on
boards for me but apparently since the
first Avatar movie Worthington has
needed crew members to hold up big cue
cards for his scene speaking in the
language this is quite funny considering
he does remember one particular word
I have no idea is the only one I could
remember we just still can't wrap our
minds around the thought of the
underwater cue cards though James
Cameron instructed his actors to say
their lines underwater but to make sure
not to blow bubbles because this could
mess up the CGI this seemed like a good
plan to the rest of the cast but poor
Kate Winslet just couldn't get a grasp
on it she was so terrified of choking on
the water that she struggled a bit with
that request it could have been a branch
tree or spear James just picked each one
out carefully when filming the scenes we
don't build the coral we build that
which they need to touch not only to
make the CGI feel more fluid but to also
give the actors something tangible on a
non-existent set that's also why a lot
of the weapons you see the actors
holding behind the scenes were more real
since it would be more difficult to just
CGI those you spend so much time
underwater it might be a little
difficult to get back on land that was
the case for Jack champion who almost
took a slip for the worst while filming
this land scene so the amount of times I
actually slipped and like slammed my hip
on the thing like you know that that's
really hard the fact that the only close
call for Jack was on land really says a
lot about the skill of this cast a
couple years after the premiere of
Avatar James and his team began brewing
a five movie plan they had already
finished the scripts for the next three
films before they even filmed two giving
them a clear outline of the franchise by
combining the filming of two and three
and even some of four they were able to
give the actors some time off before
jumping into full gear in the next set
of films VFX supervisor Joe lateri spoke
about filming so many at once and how to
deal with the chaos saying story wise
there was some overlap with the sets
that needed to be built but we were
going to focus on three first Stephen
Lang struggled a lot to get past this
naturally kind personality to play the
colonel that he kind of starved himself
every morning some of us can't agree
that this is a great way to put someone
in a bad mood but it doesn't end there
for his preparation he also likes to
work out for long periods of time and
look at himself in the mirror I get in
front of the mirror have a good look at
myself preem for a little while remember
when Disney acquired 21st Century Fox
well that happened while James was
getting a three-hour Avatar 2 picture in
the can this caused quite a bit of
ruckus with the new company but he was
able to convince the team it was
justified the way he put it because it's
a complicated linear narrative which is
the worst scenario for trying to shorten
you've got a complex story servicing a
lot of characters and it's like dominoes
falling this has to happen for that to
happen you're not following a bunch of
parallel plot lines in a way that you
could take a lot out Keith Winslet held
her breath for a whopping 7 minutes and
15 seconds breaking the record Tom
Cruise had set during mission impossible
the crazy thing about this one is that
Kate literally learned to do this in
three weeks this was really the biggest
reason she took the role in the first
place too just to get some free
underwater training for Sigourney Weaver
this was a challenge but a challenge she
welcomed I want to become the teenager
that I used to be and see where she and
Carrie meet she did a lot to prepare for
this role including jumping in on a few
classes filled with teenagers that may
not have been a good thing at times but
she all in all found it a very enjoyable
experience there was just a lightness in
her in her being you know why Steven has
to do so much to get into character he's
the set's nicest guy his co-stars attest
to him being the exact opposite of his
character and just can't fathom how
quickly he can switch on and off slaying
is the nicest person you'll ever meet
unless he's in character James Cameron
sort of had a laid-back experience with
the whole thing only having to focus on
his actors performances the camera as
well but a lot of the times the camera
moves were done digitally or he just put
full trust in his cinematographers the
long-awaited reunion of James Cameron
and Kate Winslet may not have happened
for this movie had it not been for a
strange Hollywood occurrence I just was
blown away Kate has always been quite
busy in her career ever since her big
role in Cameron's Titanic it almost
seemed impossible for her to star in any
Avatar movie all it took was Cameron
mentioning her being underwater for most
of the film that she agreed to take on
the challenge he said hey we got we have
to get you in and we have to get you big
and blue and I said I'd love that oh and
by the way you know this is the only
time she's ever worked with the same
director twice pretty strange Hollywood
occurrence for sure
if you're listening to this on your
phone you might want to hide it before
James Cameron sees bad things happen to
those on their phone but if you are
brave enough we're looking at all the
coolest secrets from the making of
Avatar number one did you realize
Sigourney Weaver didn't just play a
younger character in the way of water
it's true she already technically was
playing a younger character in the first
movie perhaps you never noticed this
little detail but her Avatar had been
around for 18 years so it looks 18 years
younger than Sigourney or even her human
character Grace Grace
well who'd you expect numbnuts creating
her Avatar was the toughest because her
features did not translate well to the
Avatar design and so the artist tasked
with making her design brought in
pictures of her from the movie Alien
number two let's start at the end the
end that never was that is the original
ending of Avatar was going to see a
pregnant natiri we are kind of glad they
didn't end it the cliche way not gonna
lie the movie was already leaning on a
ton of them ones that had already gone
out of style in the 90s so it's for the
best the forest will heal
hearts of the people
the people number three he's coming
supposedly if your cell phone went off
James Cameron would nail gun them to a
wall he did that with like 20 apparently
right above the exit sign let that be a
reminder to everyone to turn it off in
theaters when the way of water comes out
number four where do you even begin when
forming a language our guess is the
little words like the where's
an entire language was created for the
navi from scratch by linguist Dr Paul R
frommer what were we going to establish
and then how was everyone else going to
meet that Criterion he was hired to
develop a language that would be easy
for actors to pronounce that didn't
resemble any existing language he
created about 1 000 words
Zoe Saldana was in charge of creating
the accent for the navi in English since
she had to speak it the most Sam
Worthington said it was easier for him
an Australian to master the navi
language than the American accent these
guys were just going off number five a
wide range of training was necessary to
get the actors militarized and then
acclimated to Nature Sam Worthington who
plays Jake actually had to do military
boot camp to bring him closer to his
character he had to learn to use
multiple different weapons so someone
came down and showed him what it's like
to hold a gun and all the other things
that would be associated with being a
while Zoe had to move completely
unhumanlike right down to working with
her bow with her elbow bent backwards so
we wanted them to have more of a animal
kind of a movement number six where did
Jurassic Park rip off all its Dino
noises from the real thing but there is
a banshee Lane which makes all kinds of
different sounds and those sounds mean
different things most of the sounds the
animals make on Pandora are recycled
noises from the Jurassic Park franchise
while the yipping and cackling sounds
made by the Viper wolves were real
spotted hyena calls
number seven they could have bummed a
smoke off of literally anybody why rely
on Tech just like almost everything else
in this movie Grace Augustine's
cigarette is CGI honestly we didn't see
that one coming number eight not that
kind of cast Jake's atrophied legs were
Prosthetics cast from the legs of a
paraplegic man with roughly the same
bone structure as Sam Sam worthington's
real legs were tucked into the
wheelchair and digitally removed in
post-production number nine we feel the
navi should also have six limbs all the
Pandora animals have six limbs it wasn't
that simple to just add two extra legs
to an earth horse though they had to
reimagine the anatomy of the characters
too they all moved like ants their front
four legs moved together but the back
two were separate the multiple breathing
orifices were inspired by air intakes on
the sides of sports cars we guess you
can get your inspiration from anywhere
what's the metaphor what are we trying
to say to the audience with every bone
and sinew that we put into this creature
number 10. make them different but not
so different that they aren't sexy James
Cameron took inspiration for the navi
from his mother who had a dream about a
tall blue woman he drew a picture of it
way back in high school too in designing
natiri one of the challenges was making
her look alien but also human enough
that Jake's attraction to her isn't
super off-putting they went through a
ton of designs I wanted people to say I
want to be one of them number 11. how
many movies can you think of really
pushed advancements as much as Avatar
none Avatar paved the way for Tekken
movies like we know it today the navi
actors had cameras attached to helmets
to capture intimate facial performances
they were able to see simple renderings
of the CGI World while filming the
actual facial capture is too complex to
map onto these characters this movie was
also the first to film using a 3D camera
number 12. when writers write often they
include a character with a personality
similar to their own for James Cameron
that was Dr Grace Augustine Sega he said
I teased him because to me I'm playing
Jim Cameron in the movie as this kind of
brilliant approach driven idealistic
perfectionist but that same somebody has
a great heart underneath so I have to
say I was always kind of channeling him
number 13. do you think the world was
ready to handle something new how do you
create music for a world that doesn't
exist the music in Avatar was a new
invention meant to not be linked in any
way to any culture Homer noted I
couldn't go off into some weird world
and present a whole new scale system or
a whole new theme system I had to try to
glue everything together no matter how
dense it is on the screen or how alien
it might be there is a thread in the
music that keeps it grounded for the
audience so they know what is going on
and how to feel number 14. one day Sam
Worthington will release a book about
his experience Sam was living in his car
at the time of his audition the person
who called him in for the audition told
him nothing about the director or the
script he was disappointed at first
thinking it was another waste of time
Matt Damon and Jake Gyllenhaal were
actually the Studio's first choices to
play Jake but James Cameron wanted to
cast the relatively unknown Sam I just
wanted to say thank you yeah thank you
number 15. Avatar is pretty ancient at
this point James Cameron promised not to
take his pay as director if Avatar
flopped this was just one reassurance
20th Century Fox had that they wouldn't
lose all their money he originally
planned to have the film completed for
release in 1999 but the technology was
just not Advanced enough to tackle the
project in a way that was financially
reasonable while a lot of people say
Avatar is just Disney's Pocahontas that
isn't the full story James had been
developing Avatar since as far back as
the 60s he smooshed four of his scripts
together and even some early concept art
from high school the first script being
xenogenesis about scientists who try to
find a new planet to live on the second
Chrysalis was about a man in a
wheelchair who has all of his sensory
inputs removed so he can journey through
his own mind the third mother was about
a company who sets up lines on other
planets the rest of the elements of the
story went to his movie Alien and the
last one wind Warriors was basically the
plot of Avatar except set on Earth in
order to develop a fully realized world
it's easy to see why you need a team of
Highly skilled and super knowledgeable
people to develop single aspects imagine
trying to come up with the language
music culture creatures and Technology
to capture it all yourself it's an
impossible task unless you've got your
master's degree in literally everything
what we're replacing is five hours in
the makeup chair having rubber glued all
over your face Avatar was
that's all thanks to everyone's
willingness to look absolutely
ridiculous on set number one let's take
a dip in the water for a second for the
Avatar sequel Kate Winslet had to learn
to hold her breath underwater while we
thought it was impossible to hold your
breath for more than a couple of minutes
we can guarantee that her record took
our breath away she got up to a whopping
7 minutes and 14 seconds I know I'm very
proud of that actually they couldn't use
scuba gear underwater so it was just
easier for her to learn to completely
obliterate her lungs we guess it's not
something I could just jump in the bath
and do right now number two so help us
there better be lots of banshees and
Avatar too they were the coolest part of
the original sadly they weren't exactly
cool without all the CGI and special
effects honestly whatever it is Sam
Worthington is riding on it's not an
alien bird it looks more like a baby toy
or maybe a knockoff mechanical bull
James Cameron's biggest question when it
came to the ban she was what is the
metaphor we're trying to get across
people have asked me what was your
inspiration what was the trigger they're
looking for some kind of proximal cause
he wanted the Banshee to be Birds of
Prey Eagles alien Eagles number three
water unnecessary life force and also a
huge pain the tracking dot technology
sure has come a long way since the first
avatar however they did run into a
problem with the tech when they found
themselves in a new environment the CGI
tracking dots would reflect off of the
water this was one of the many
challenges the new environment had on
technology that was no big deal in the
jungle number four the stunt actors
would have had their work cut out for
them the nice thing about hiring stunt
actors for a CGI film is you don't need
to worry about matching doubles so much
look at the special skills these actors
had at their disposal Vine swinging come
on what Reuben Langdon hits the ground
harder than anybody I know and for the
sequel Sigourney Weaver revealed that
all of the actors had to learn parkour
number five they couldn't just find some
basketball players to play the navi
notice that the humans aren't present in
the filming of this Scene It makes
perfect sense you can't have giant
actors and Tiny actors at the same time
you'd have to film them separately and
then splice them together one way to
nail the scene was with pool noodles
okay it's probably not pool noodles but
it looks like cool noodles whatever
floats your goat right number six we bet
this jungle beast is just a putty tat on
the inside it's all about the muscles
when creating the life like otherworldly
CGI creatures like the thanatore you've
got to work from the inside out if you
miss a layer it can be spotted in your
work they built the skeleton for the
thanator and attached muscles to it over
top a black armored six-legged Panther
from hell
this is the description the alien jungle
cat had 10 years before its design came
to be it didn't change much from James
Cameron's original Vision number seven
good things come in six a similar
process to what they went through with
the thanator they also did with the dire
horses they had to completely
re-engineer a horse's anatomy in order
to make the hexapedal design work to
capture that much Nuance in the
performance of the animal can come from
only one place studying the real thing
yes that's right they actually brought
in real horses for the actors to ride
number eight we take these
groundbreaking Technologies for granted
these days the look of the navi was not
impressing people enough so they went to
WETA to build a new face and muscle skin
system because characters are mostly
naked they had their work cut out for
them to make sure it actually looks
authentic you can't hide behind cloth
it's got more personality it's got my
soul to make the skin look real
animators had to work inside out
creating bone structures and muscles
number nine honestly we wouldn't mind a
nice cryo sleep right now the cryo
Chambers are probably the closest thing
to a set avatar ever got aside from A
Touch of Green Screen it's all real
anything that can look technical in
sci-fi was probably done more practical
than the alien counterparts anything
like the beautiful Pandora backdrops or
nature most likely are nearly entirely
if not entirely CGI a range of different
Vehicles was used for aircrafts we say
Vehicles lightly by the way they were
metal shells with different capabilities
some were strapped to wire and carried
around and some were just big metal
cages number 10. Avatar really set the
bar for intricate lighting spherical
harmonics is a data representation of
how light interacts with surfaces this
technology was first developed for the
first Avatar movie and one WETA an award
it's necessary for creating realistic
hair and eyes number 11. this is the
strangest Stampede we've ever seen it's
in incredible the depth these actors are
able to bring without having much to
work with even trees are just metal
racks and creatures a human Stampede
with baseballs on metal rods it was
heard you number 12 usually imagination
is left up to Stage or voice actors but
not for Avatar they created a teeny tiny
obstacle course for Sam Worthington to
run through and honestly we're shook so
much of the world was shot in this
high-tech cold environment we're not
sure whether to be disappointed or
impressed although film has shifted away
from digital effects recently as
audiences favor the Practical these days
but we bet the pendulum will swing back
after Avatar 2. number 13. the doctor
has arrived the navi hand is just a blue
glove it looks like a surgical glove
less than two dozen people were suited
up here despite there being hundreds of
other Navi added later we can only
wonder how they were included number 14
actors can do a lot but but not
everything they're swapped out for their
stunt doubles for a moment see it the
moment natiri throws sute off Jake is
this true number 15. none of the stunts
were CGI folks okay they were a CGI but
that doesn't mean the actors and stunt
people didn't still have to follow
through with them honestly we're quite
impressed with this it's really gonna
hurt in the morning number 16. Jake and
the giant beanstalk of all the things
that were more on the Practical side
this was not one of the ones we would
have expected to be built and yes they
did call it the Beanstalk number 17. all
of the clothing was hand stitched and
yet got no Awards moat's ceremonial gown
was made in multiple different Fabrics
until they managed to get exactly the
right weight that would move the way
they wanted it to move sutay's battle
fringes were made up of different
weights and fabrics they did wind tunnel
tests on fabric and then after that it
was weta's job to figure out how to
incorporate that into the animation
number team realize Realize Real Lies
and of course the thing we were afraid
of is what people have sometimes called
the Dead Eye effect mounting cameras
directly to actors heads is how they
solved this issue with a tight fitting
carbon fiber helmet that was molded to
their heads to capture every minute
detail number 19 Avatar is the reason
single camera TV shows exist they were
using them all we said well we have a
fully virtual world let's shoot it in a
fully virtual way they had two
completely different camera systems
taking it from a point where you had to
wait months to see something where he's
getting in real time one was a virtual
camera system to capture actors in a
virtual environment
frame his virtual camera up and see his
character there on the Fly the other was
to shoot live-action actors and sets in
3D there's no way to hide so every day
you have to be truthful number 20. they
went into the forest half naked for
research taking the actors into nature
really informed their performance Upon
returning to the mocap filming space the
actors found they retained the
experience the memories of the little
things like how it feels for your foot
to step in mud James Cameron found
inspiration for many visuals by sending
the actors out there too but I think the
biggest part of it that was valuable was
just the kind of kinesthetic sense
memory number 21 on top of fight
training learning a new language etc etc
the actors also needed to learn
choreography all of the movement was
specially choreographed but sadly many
dance numbers were actually cut out of
the film without the choreographer the
navi would have been missing an integral
part of their characteristics as a
community number 22 James Cameron grew
tired waiting for the tech to catch up
so the Avatar crew invented them
ourselves Jim wrote Avatar way back in
1994. it was meant to be made right
after Titanic but the technology just
wasn't there yet so the script got put
off until it could catch up in order to
honor Jim's Vision they got caught up in
2005 when they asked Fox for the time
and money to research the technology
could we really do the things we think
we
think number 23 before Avatar there was
Avatar before they ever had their actors
cast They cast two temporary actors to
create a 37 second clip why see yes
why save just creating this prototype
would have cost a fortune number 24.
cats were a huge part of the navi design
I feel like I'm blue and I'm nine feet
tall and I'm as sexy as hell arriving at
the design of the navi was no easy task
Jim always knew he wanted them to be
blue but the animal features like the
cat ears tail and nose as well as
lemur-like eyes came organically along
the way at first they were designed to
look amphibious and then more alien with
antennae and such they kept coming back
to blue skinned humans and that wasn't
working either but the big problem was
Jim didn't feel he could tell a love
story if the characters weren't
beautiful I wanted people to say I want
to be one of them they put the actors in
these sphere shapes and photographed
them from every angle with different
lighting patterns to study the actor's
facial features and design characters
based on that number 25 do you think
they let the actor see what was up on
screen to give them a sense of the magic
the stunning bioluminescent tree is
nothing more than a few threads on a
metal pole but you probably figured that
out by now but what they could see
behind their specialized camera was
already nearly good enough for a video
game maybe not for theaters but for a
video game while the Wood Sprite was
puppeted on a stick buckle up fellow
adventurers we're heading back to
bandura that's right the wait for Avatar
2 the way of water has finally come to
an end and to say it lightly it's going
to be well worth the wait there's so
many Secrets surrounding the making of
this massive Blockbuster so hold your
breath we're diving deep into it number
one James Cameron was determined in
Making a Splash return to the cinemas so
much so that he was having his cast take
dunks in a design pool for days on end
his realistic approach to shooting in
the specific environment LED designers
to construct a massive 900 000 gallon
water tank for the actors to basically
live in James would sit and direct his
actors from above and Kate Winslet would
simply hold her breath till the take was
done we quite literally mean that but
we'll get more into that a little later
for now let's just stay a little jealous
over the paid pool days the cast got
during principal photography number two
now you might be thinking filming in a
giant water tank is cool and all but
how'd they do the incredible motion
capture work down there while the answer
is simple James Cameron and a whole lot
of money and time we are already aware
of this creativity and dedication to
every film project but he literally
developed New Motion capture technology
to use in the water all it took was a
little brain power and a ton of ping
pong balls this Tech aloud visual
effects editors to more realistically
depict the way water interacts with the
characters bodies but sometimes the
process became a little painstaking
according to Cameron scuba bubbles would
create too much noise in our performance
capture system so no matter how long the
scene took if it took two three four
minutes to shoot everybody was holding
their breath number three so if you've
held your breath up until this point
congrats that's much longer than we ever
could but you're not much of a record
breaker considering Kate Winslet holds
the breath-holding title for a whopping
7 minutes and 30 seconds she was very
proud of her accomplishment and having
trained for months with Navy Seals on
the technique it looks like she got the
hang of it I learned how to breath hold
and held my breath for seven minutes
which is completely true and I'm very
proud of that Tom Cruise may need to
take a few pointers from her and a few
from Sigourney Weaver too that's right
at 72 years of age Weaver was able to
hold her breath for just over six
minutes both of these actresses really
deserve a breather after the films
finished shooting number four the
Titanic film Mastermind decided to ditch
The Old Ship Tech and bring on a couple
new ones and being that this is
Cameron's film they had to create them
both on a massive scale with the sneak
peek at the Matador and pick a door we
can surmise that they are just cooler
versions of submarine trains and boats
number five dipping a camera underwater
or any other electronic is probably not
the best idea and with that in mind
cinematographer and Camera inventor
Powell Axel needed to whip up a camera
to do the job right actel just decided
to upgrade his camera to shoot 6K
footage at a distance of 20 feet this
way filmmakers can get the quality they
want without risk of damage to the
equipment number six acting underwater
is difficult enough but can you imagine
dancing underwater yeah we couldn't and
it looked like the rest of the cast
opted out of this Venture because James
went ahead and hired trained aquatic
dancers to perform the underwater
numbers number seven the cast and crew
of The Avatar franchise really grew
close and became attached to the
characters specifically for Zoe Saldana
who played the fierce natiri of Pandora
she has become so invested in her
character that she got very emotional
after a special preview view of Avatar 2
by just watching a mere 20 minutes of
the film so we cried and cheered for her
character's journey I was speechless
they just I was moved to tears if this
preview made her feel this way can you
imagine how the theaters will be after
watching the entire thing a tissue box
with the purchase of every movie ticket
would be a big plus number eight
director James Cameron has a plan and
this complex plan involves at least
three more sequels we haven't even
watched the second one however it seems
he just can't wait to make them with the
comments we've heard by the actors of
the movie they seem to be all exhausted
from shooting two movies at a time I
just sit here at my desk and I cry all
day long there's no solid news as to
when they will be filming the others but
we can imagine it will be soon Cameron
knows the pressures of making sequels
but with the Innovations he's made to
make the film perfect we can expect he
knows what he's doing as much of the
hard work that is put in means more
magic for the audiences so we guess it's
a win win for both parties number nine
enough about our Praises for the great
James Cameron let's get the gas stake on
their boss no bias of course you know
Jim he's a very loyal man and he keeps
the same people on board put all that
aside we can't imagine why they'd work
with him for so long and show so much
praise for his work if they didn't like
working with them plus they're already
at the point of nicknames in their
friendship with him which means they're
basically family now Jim trusts the
people that he surrounds us with and we
all trust in him number 10 a successful
sequel must take the best from the first
and add brand new aspects and well James
looks to be pretty well versed in
audience expectations and won't fail to
impress since he had such a long time to
plan out the franchise he decided to do
a little research in the ocean this made
some pretty big headlines back in the
day and he really credits the success of
those voyages as huge Inspirations for
the ocean environment of Avatar 2.
number 11. it's been over 10 years since
Avatar hit the silver screens the
multi-billion dollar film United some of
the finest actors of their generations
with Cameron bringing back the original
cast and characters it seems very
surreal to everyone on set like Zoe
being attached to her character so was
every one of the actors she's my
favorite I've gotten to be able to live
in her skin they not only love their
Newfound family but they also really
wanted to get going on another James
Cameron spectacle number 12. we now know
that the planing of the Avatar franchise
started being planned as far back as
2012 but what took so long some can say
that James's ocean excursions were to
blame as we learn more and more about
the scale of the production in general
it looks like James took a decade long
Hiatus to play the Right Moves number 13
secret secrets are no fun unless you're
Sam Worthington who really thinks
they're amusing no he's not rubbing it
in our faces he he's actually keeping
the secret safe for our own enjoyment I
like the surprise of it I like that
we've been very secretive for the last
15 years and while some of the cast
knows the inner workings of the story
they too just want us to enjoy a fresh
new take number 14. the family is all
United and stronger than ever with a few
hints at the upcoming plot James had
just a taste to give us they have family
bonds they teach each other they have
taught culture as this sequel will take
place 15 years after the original Sully
has created a family and protected it
for a very long time and with the
original enemies making a return
invasion of Pandora this one's going to
be all about surviving as a family
number 15 when Cinema lovers think of
family who else comes to mind more than
Vin Diesel aside from any Pandora family
barbecues Finn was announced to be in
the film well maybe not officially
announced but after meeting a few times
with Cameron diesel had this to say I
have spent time with him but I have not
filmed yet I love James Cameron and I
loved the series I think it's safe to
say that we will be working together
[Music]
so that's what Pandora actually looks
like James Cameron's Avatar is one of
the most visually stunning films ever
made but what does it look like without
all the CGI the animators have taken
what the actors are doing and gone even
beyond that natiri lives a pretty unique
lifestyle as one of the Navi on the
planet of Pandora one of the things that
we see natiri partake in is drinking
water from a leaf but because director
James Cameron loves to rely on
Technology Innovation the way that the
scene was actually filmed without CGI
may surprise you Zoe Saldana was
required to work with a gray plastic
Contraption to model as the leaf while
holding a water bottle covered in duct
tape to simulate water coming from the
tape we guess that's why they call it
movie Magic it's the most high-tech film
in terms of its execution you may or may
not have had an awkward kiss in your
life but it probably wasn't as awkward
as it was for Sam Worthington and Zoe
Saldana when they had to kiss as Jake
and natiri while filming Avatar while in
the movie itself with all the added CGI
the scene plays out romantically without
all the CGI Worthington and Saldana had
to kiss with their motion captured
jumpsuits and with green dots all over
their face so that the motion capture on
their characters CGI bodies would be
accurate and more real we created a
manually operated gimbal
that they could balance on one of the
most exciting action scenes in all of
Avatar was definitely the flying Banshee
obviously a lot of CGI was needed to be
done to bring the Banshee to life as
there's no living real world counterpart
to the creature in order to capture Jake
flying on the Banshee Sam Worthington
was required to fly on the back of a
moving plastic structure where he'd be
flung around with wires all while
wearing the motion capture suit honestly
we think we just prefer the ride at
Disney world that seems a bit more
comfortable see them flying these things
they're working hard it's always intense
whenever anybody in a movie yells but
when a blue-skinned alien like natiri
yells it's even more powerful
you will never be one of the people
despite the goofy motion capture get up
and the silly plastic Navi ears Saldana
was still able to be quite intimidating
on set layers of additional CGI were
added in order to make natiri and the
rest of the navi look even more real in
the film you definitely wouldn't want to
tick knit here hurry off I at least have
no idea that I'm wearing this I feel
like I'm blue and I'm nine feet tall the
big villain of Avatar was Stephen Lang's
Colonel Miles gorich who unlike a lot of
the other characters who required CG is
actually a human one might assume that
the Colonel's Mac suit design was all
CGI but they would be wrong the main
core design of the suit was a practical
effect but it was the arm and the
digital screens that were later added
with additional CGI work in order to
make the suit a more formidable Force to
the navi the final product proved to be
quite the treat to the navi and made
Lang's Colonel an even more memorable
villain with rumors that he'll be back
for the sequel he may even bring that
neck suit back oh yeah who's bad that's
right one of the first dangerous
creatures that Jake Encounters in the
jungles of Pandora is the fierce
thanatore while the thanatore is quite
intimidating on screen the creature
wasn't much to look at before the CGI
was added in fact before the CGI was
added standing in for the thanatore was
a red tennis ball on a long gray stick
held by a crew member in order for the
actors to go on cue the crew member
holding the thanatore's stand-in would
lunge at them life on Pandora would
likely be much easier if all the navi
had to worry about was a tennis ball on
a stick Cameron has a knack for working
with actors and actresses he's worked
with before so of course one of the
actresses he brought with him to Avatar
was his alien star Sigourney Weaver
Weaver plays Grace in the film and
doesn't just play the character in human
form but also as a Navy while even in
her Navi form Grace typically wears
human clothes behind the scenes Weaver
had to still wear a motion capture suit
to convincingly play Grace's Navi avatar
from Alien to Ghostbusters Sigourney
Weaver has clearly made her Mark in the
Sci-Fi genre we had horses galloping
around this place it wasn't just the
human actors who were behind motion
capture technology on the set of Avatar
as actual horses were used under motion
capture technology for the dire horses
the horses were equipped with dots on
their body much like their human
co-stars in order for them to be
transformed later with visual effects
the horses were brought to the Sound
Stage of the film and Cameron would film
the actors behind the navi riding the
horses with the special technology that
would allow him to be their CGI
counterparts as they were filming who
knows maybe those horses went on to take
other motion capture roles as well
despite all the extensive CGI and motion
capture present throughout Avatar that
didn't mean the actors had to perform
less stunts in fact it was quite the
opposite whenever we saw the navi
climbing up the vines of the ominous
floating rocks on Pandora Cameron had
the actors behind the navi climb a
similar structure all in their motion
capture gear the final CGI was added
later but still that didn't make the
climb not dangerous though you can't
really become one of the navi without at
least getting a little bit rugged with
yourself and your environment motion
capture wasn't always available when
capturing scenes with the navi
especially when they shared the screen
with the human characters when recording
the scene where Jake first wakes up in
his Navi form Cameron filmed the actors
playing the human doctors working around
an empty Gurney behind the lens of
Cameron's camera he was able to see the
CGI character we went to Kauai we went
way up in the mountains and we acted out
the scenes before the motion capture
work was done for Avatar Sam Worthington
and Zoe Saldana filmed without their
suits half naked in Hawaii this would be
done in order so James Cameron could
know how to plan all their scenes that
would need motion capture such as the
bow and arrow scene the tree of voices
is perhaps one of the most gorgeous
looking set pieces in all of Avatar but
behind the scenes and without the CGI
that sacred tree wasn't much to look at
in fact the trees were mainly just
pieces of rope that were used to
simulate the long leaves and branches of
the trees that natiri would present to
Jake the final CGI would be added into
the production later to say these stunt
guys I mean they really just they gave
us their all the navi clearly have a
different culture than what we're used
to and Cameron wanted to display some of
the tribal customs of the main tribe in
the film the group of four actors may
not have had the biggest roles in the
film but that didn't mean their work
wasn't difficult these actors ultimately
had to memorize a tribal Dance of the
navi in all their motion capture Suits
now that's true commitment to the craft
if this was CG could have moved that 30
seconds so the whole time I was shooting
the virtual camera I was complaining
that it wasn't live action well there
were times on set where James Cameron
and his crew had more accurate models of
the Dragon assault ships there were
times where the models wouldn't be
enough in order to film the scene
Cameron had the motion capture board use
a metal-like chair in the middle of the
set that would be moved around by crew
members a fan was also placed in front
of the actors in order to properly
capture the wind blowing in their
characters faces while the real set may
not have been as exciting as actually
flying on a ship as a Navi on Pandora
the cast and crew certainly made the
most of it develop the most lightweight
3D system possible so it's very
sophisticated technology the 3D much
like the CGI had recorded in a distinct
way using two
this scene where the kernel is attacked
on his Mech by one of the navi used two
cameras to perfect the 3D and the CGI
One camera would be used for the live
action elements and the other would be
used for the CG 3D elements I need you
to put up 10 million dollars to prove we
can make this movie Avatar is one of the
most influential films made in the last
20 years and the CGI is an important
reason why from Cameron's innovative
ways of incorporating the CGI to the
commitment for authenticity by the cast
and crew Avatar's production was clearly
top-notch what was your favorite CGI
element in James Cameron's Avatar